let's learn a little bit about sequences
in series so what's the sequence well
sequence is just a bunch of numbers in
some order you know the most difficult
sequence is one two
three
four you get the point uh and and what's
a series well it's often represented as
just a sum of sequences a sum of a
sequence so for example the arithmetic
sequence sorry the arithmetic series is
just the sum of the arithmetic
sequence so
1 plus 2 plus three plus we could keep
going until maybe some number this is
called
the arithmetic series
arithmetic
series
and nothing too too fancy here uh but
before we move forward let's let's get a
notation for how we can represent these
sums without necessarily having to write
out all of the digits or having to keep
you know doing this dot dot dot plus
notation and that's and that notation is
sigma notation
sigma
that's an upper case
and how do you use sigma notation well
let's say i wanted to represent this
arithmetic series
so i would say well let's add up a bunch
of let's call them k's this is an
arbitrary variable and we'll start at k
equals one
we'll start at k equals one and we'll go
to k is equal to
big n
and this is the exact same thing so we
first say make k equal to one and then
we add it to k is equal to two
plus three and we go all the way until
n minus one
and then plus n
so this is a the sigma notation for the
arithmetic series
before i move on i think this is a good
time just to like
learn a little bit more about the
arithmetic series we'll actually focus
on this one
and the geometric series because those
are the two that you'll you'll see uh
most often and then once you learn
calculus i'll show you the the power and
uh taylor series which is exact taylor
series is a specific version of a power
series but let's let's let's play around
with this earth i keep wanting to say
arithmetic but arithmetic either way
series
so let's call the sum s
let's say that this is equal to the sum
from k is equal to 1
to n
of k
which is equal to just like we said
1 plus 2
plus
3 and we'll just keep adding them you
know dot dot to a bunch of numbers to
big n minus 1
plus big n right
fair enough
now
bear with me a second and i'm just going
to write that same exact sum again
but i'm just going to write it in
reverse order and i i think it's it's
it's intuitive to you that it doesn't
matter what order i add up numbers in
they'll add up to the same number but 2
plus 1 is the same thing as 1 plus 2
right so let me write this exact same
sum but i'll write it in reverse order
so that's the same thing as
n plus
n minus 1 plus
n minus 2 plus and the pluses keep going
plus 2 plus 1. this is the exact same
sum just in reverse order
and i did that for a reason because now
i'm going to add both sides of this
equation i'm going to take the s plus s
well that's just 2s
and that's going to equal
this sum plus this sum
and this is i'm i'm i wrote this so that
the sum becomes
clean and and why do i say that well
let's add up corresponding terms we
could have added up any terms but since
they all have to add up let's just add
the 1 plus the n and we'll add the 2
plus the 2 plus the n minus 1 then we'll
have 3 plus the n minus 2
and so forth and i think you'll see in a
second or maybe you already realize why
i'm doing this so i have 1 plus the n
the 2 plus the n minus 1
the 3 and the n minus 2
all the way the n minus 1 and the two
the n and the one
what is what's one plus n well that's
just n plus one right
what's two plus
n minus one
well that's also n plus one
right what's 3 plus n minus 2
i think you could guess it's n minus 1.
and we just keep doing that and what's n
minus 2 plus 2
i'll say this is a plus
n plus 1.
and what's n plus one well that's just n
plus one of course
so my question to you is how many of
these n plus ones are there well there
are n of them right each n plus one
corresponds to each of these terms so
they're n of these so instead of just
adding n plus one n times we could say
that this is just
n times
n plus one
so we have two times the sum is equal to
n times n plus one and we could divide
both sides by two and we get the sum is
equal to n
times
n plus one
over two
now why is this
neat or why is this cool at all well
first of all we found out a way to to
sum this
sigma notation up we got kind of a a
well-defined formula
and what makes this especially cool is
you could use this for
for
low-end parlor tricks and what do i mean
by that well you can go up to someone
and you can say
you could say well
how quickly do you think i can add up
the numbers between
one end what am i doing
oh between 100 and you know people say
oh take a little time 1 plus 2 plus 3
and you say well it takes me no time at
all
because this is what i can do
so the sum
and i just want to show you that you can
use different variables from b equals 1
we're taking the variable b
to
right that's the sum from 1 to 100 and
we figured out what that formula is
it's going to be 100
times 101
over two
well what's a hundred times a hundred
and one it's just gonna be a hundred one
with two zeros right
two zeros ten thousand one hundred
over two
and that equals five thousand
and fifty that's pretty neat instead of
having to say one plus two plus three
plus
plus ninety-eight plus ninety-nine plus
one hundred this would take you some
time and there's a very good chance
you'd make a careless mistake we could
just plug into this formula which we
proved and hopefully you understood and
said that equals 50 50.
you could even buy something more
impressive the sum from one to a
thousand what's the sum from one to a
thousand well our formula remember it
was n times n plus one over two so if n
is equal to a thousand
then what's our sums a thousand
times one thousand and one
over two
which is equal to we'll just add three
zeros to this
thousand one one
three
sorry i think that was my first burp
ever on one of these videos
i should re-record it but i'm going to
move forward um
that kind of disconcerted me a little
bit i eaten too much anyway
divided by 2 and what is that what's uh
let's see it'll be
500 let's see this is a million
half of a million is five is five
hundred thousand
five hundred thousand
five hundred
and that would have taken you forever to
do manually but based on what we this
formula we just got you you know how to
do it very very quickly
so that's the arithmetic series
let's do another one this is another
typical series that that you might see
actually this one you'll see a lot in
your life especially if you go into
finance or
uh really a whole a whole series of
scientific you know
this shows up a lot and this is called
the geometric series
and the geometric series is essentially
you take
x and i'll say i'll do it generally
where i just take a variable x
and i say well no let me just not take
an x let me just take some some number
so let's say
from let's say some number a to the k
from
i don't know let's say from
k is equal to 0 to k is equal to n well
what does that mean well that means
a to the 0
right k0 plus a one plus a squared plus
a to the third
plus and you could keep going plus a to
the n minus one plus a to this is a plus
plus a to the n minus 2. this is called
the geometric series because you and and
it might not be obvious to you but this
type of growth where you keep increasing
the exponent this is called geometric
growth
so how do you take the sum of this well
let's let's see if we can do a similar
trick although this trick will be
involve one more step so let's call the
sum let's call the sum s
let's call it
the sum
from k equals 0
to n
of a to the k
and that of course is equal to what i
just wrote i probably didn't have to do
it like this
a squared plus
plus
a to the n minus 1 plus
a to the n minus 2.
now let's define another
sum and i'm going to call that
a s
a s actually i'm about to run up time so
i'll continue this in the next video